[Music]
many people visiting Sochi for the
Olympics have been complaining about how
terrible the hotel rooms are over there
yeah we've all heard these stories
really some crazy League bad conditions
are being reported in the Sochi hotel
rooms so here to talk about this live
from Russia is Sochi's public relations
director Yuri Tamara
let's get him here sleepyhead attraction
oh good good good evening mr. Tanner ah
good to see you it's hello Conan I am
pleasing to make your acquaintance I can
talk long very very busy well mr.
chairman you don't look that busy I have
to say you really don't
oh hello what's that you'll love your
hotel room thank you for sharing that at
this particular time okay mr. Tamara how
do you respond all the criticism about
the hotels in Sochi no criticisms
everything 100% hunky and dory okay well
then how do you explain this photo of a
sign asking people not to flush toilet
paper down the toilet come on Conan why
throw toilet paper in toilet when you
can take it home a souvenir okay no no
who would do that you'd be surprised
oh hello what's that you love your
toilet paper souvenir I am most pleased
that you told me that fact at this exact
moment yeah Hey look your phone is not
even ringing when you pick it up it's on
vibrate oh forgot
Nicholas alright what about the guy who
found this is true a wild dog sleeping
in his bed what about that I don't know
dog is not wild
he's hotel employee I'm getting a call
hello what's that you're glad there was
hotel employee dog in your bed dog
protected you from bears that's great
nothing about the hotels the opening
ceremonies had a big problem the fifth
ring of the Olympic symbol would not
open people said it looked like an
asterisk check that out look it looks
like asterisks that's because it really
is an asterisk Conan what are you
talking about what do you mean does just
look closer okay here's the asterisk in
and down yeah yes hello President Putin
well what an honor sir yes I agree no
one is buying any of this crap okay I
should just kill myself all right
oh well stupid Russian gun doesn't work
how will I die
yeah
okay who says
[Applause]
they're just rather just cuddling I've
been in comedy a long time the dumbest
line I think I've heard in his sketches
now how will I die